right let's return now to the situation
in uh Sudan and joining me now hopefully
is Lakshmi parfa uh Sarah say a travel
blogger from the US currently stuck in
the capital Khartoum and Lakshmi I hope
you can hear me because we have had
problems with communicating with you
understandably but uh can you just tell
me the latest situation and what is
happening is the fighting still going on
it's been very very confusing the
fighting is definitely still going on
there's been you know announcements of
ceasefires there's supposed to be a
72-hour ceasefire for Eve actually and
it lasted maybe 72 minutes at most
um so it's actually increased in terms
of just like the sounds of fighting it
has shifted though it seems to have
shifted away from the airports towards
military areas in the city
um you can tell by all the smoke in the
sky just now is on like a different side
um
so it's been yeah it's just been very
very chaotic um and very very loud so it
seems like uh you know I think this is
the third ceasefire that's failed now so
I I don't have many hopes of like a LOL
happening
um at this point the power and water was
out for four days it came back last
night and it actually went out again
um so people are kind of struggling with
access to resources right now and
um right now this like residential area
that I'm in like these like few streets
have stayed relatively safe enough so
people are walking around it can go to
the market so that's good
um but it's it's all very very tense and
fighting about yourself yeah I don't
know sorry forgive me um can you get out
and about can you go out and get food
and water or is it simply too dangerous
to venture out
so right here within like the these
couple of streets it's been safe enough
to go out
um most times of the day there was a
skirmish that happened like earlier this
morning and so there was some Crossfire
um but other than that I've been able to
walk outside to the market I haven't
felt like it's
um a life-threatening thing to do
however if or to walk like five ten
minutes
then that I would not feel safe doing
that
and people have been told to stay where
they are and to
um continue to effectively Hide Away
have you had any word from the American
authorities from any authorities Western
authorities about what you should do in
terms of getting out maybe eventually
yeah I mean there are uh embassies that
are trying to evacuate citizens but the
problem right now is that because no
ceasefire has held for any amount of
time there is no way for anyone to like
safely land anywhere in the city to
evacuate citizens so right now
um
the U.S embassy and other ones that I've
heard about have just kind of been on
standby now because they can't really do
anything until there's some like
quieting
um because it's just been like heavy
heavy fire
um fighting
so until then the the orders are to to
shelter in place and um there has been
like some looting and
unrest happening in in the areas like
closer to the airport so they made note
of that so kind of saying to just like
stay where you are keep quiet and if
someone shows up then kind of you know
like
um
care for your life give what you have
um yeah
so the yeah tell me about yourself I
mean are you okay do you you you must be
first of all terrified but otherwise are
you managing okay are you in contact
with the people you need to be in
contact with
yeah I've had enough Network
um so that's been really really kind of
a lifesaver so I've been able to keep in
contact with family and friends in the
outside world
um and to be able to keep up to date on
like what's happening with security wise
so that's good and I mean I'm mostly
staying insane it's it's a it's a scary
situation and it's very confusing and
every time I think about okay what
should I do there's just no
good option that I can
um that I can really think of so that's
kind of difficult
um but
um you know I'm
I'm hopeful one thing that's been really
really comforting is that all the
Sudanese people around us like neighbors
and everything have been super helpful
like
helping us get water charge our phones
if they have power
um help in giving us food when for iftar
um because it's Ramadan here before so
everyone was fasting but everyone has
been really really helpful so it's been
really nice
um and it's been like in and out of like
anxious and then just kind of also just
bored because they're sitting inside and
the power is out so there's no air
conditioning it's really really hot
um so yeah just kind of like waiting
waiting to see what what happens
and the the ceasefires they keep saying
that they're gonna have ceasefires but
they never seem to materialize and of
course it needs a ceasefire of some
certainly several hours if not days to
get people out I mean presumably you
would you would leave would you at the
first opportunity that came
Lakshmi did you hear me
um I the end cut off there right I was
just saying I mean presumably if there
was a ceasefire and there was a a moment
to get out you would do that you you
want to get out
um if there was a good opportunity to to
leave then
yeah I don't see any any reason to not
take it
um
yeah but I think
um I think it's gonna be hard to find
those good opportunities at this point
okay well this is also leaving cartoon
is difficult because the evacuations
will happen here so
like
what to do
okay well listen we we hope uh things
turn out okay and uh we hope you stay
well and thank you very much for talking
to us and maybe we'll uh try to talk to
you again in the coming in the coming
days Lakshmi